the UK's Prince Harry is about to become
the first senior Royal to testify in
court since the 19th century the prince
says more than 100 articles published by
the mirror group newspapers between 1991
and 2011 contain information obtained
illegally such as via phone hacking
Harry says his family members including
King Charles were targeted by
journalists he's one of four claimants
saying the stories harmed his
relationships and mental health the
mural group has admitted to phone
hacking but denies Harry's allegations
so as former editor Piers Morgan his
lawsuit is one of seven that Prince
Harry and his wife Meghan Markle have
filed against media companies in the UK
and the US
Allah correspondent to Harry Fawcett
joins us live from outside the high
court in London Harry proceedings are
expected to get underway shortly what's
happening in court today
that's right the the dates proceedings
that you just start in just over 15
minutes and they are uh to include the
setting out of the case by Prince
Harry's lawyers against mirror group
newspapers now if he is going to be
there for the start of that he doesn't
have long uh in which to arrive we do
know that he's expected to give evidence
in the witness box probably tomorrow
Tuesday so he doesn't necessarily have
to be here on this day but it is
nonetheless a very heightened atmosphere
around here given the the significance
of all this the case has been brought by
more than 100 individuals against mirror
group newspapers of them a subset of
four representative cases is being heard
Prince Harry is of course the most high
profile of those his lawyers allege that
in more than 140 stories there were some
form of unlawful practices used either
through phone hacking or through
deception or through the unlawful use of
private investigators to invade the
privacy of The Prince and his family
members and people around him to try to
get stories about him he is as I say due
to give evidence probably on Tuesday
that will be the most sort of high
profile part of this case so far he's
likely to be cross-examined of course by
the lawyers for Mirror group newspapers
mgn denies that in 28 of the 33 cases
being held being considered by the court
that it did anything unlawful in the
five remaining cases it says that it is
not admitting to any such uh use of
unlawful practices essentially giving
the burden of proof to Prince Harry and
his lawyers it is highly unusual isn't
it Harry for a member of the royal
family to expose themselves to scrutiny
in this way but for Harry this is
something of a personal mission
it is of course Prince Harry has been a
very unusual Royal in recent years both
in terms of leaving uh the UK setting up
home in the United States with his wife
Megan but this is very much the legacy
of what happened to his mother Princess
Diana of course dying in that car crash
in Paris uh pursued by photographers
members of the paparazzi on on
motorbikes that is a of course a very
deep personal wound that he's carried
for many years it's something that he
sees reflected he says in the treatment
of his wife Megan he says a lot of that
treatment has been racist as well and so
this is part of something that he has
turned a sort of a life's work a mission
to recast the media landscape in the UK
to try to ensure that privacy of public
figures is more closely guarded uh and
in that's enforced by the law but also
given that there have been judgments
against individual journalists in the
past given that there have been hundreds
of millions of dollars in settlements
paid out privately by Major media groups
that has all happened but what hasn't
really happened is the sort of personal
accountability that he seems to want to
enact against the highest ranks of media
Executives the senior editorial teams
the owners of these companies his team
is trying to prove that they knew what
was going on uh that of course has been
denied and we wait to see how it all
plays out in court over the next couple
of days we certainly will and we'll
bring all the events to viewers as they
happen thanks very much Harriet for
joining us there from London